si on vole vers la france le taureau la
compétition d'air france on vole vers
les états unis à des compagnies
aériennes donc il ya de la compétition à
l'international mais du côté de
domestiques qui avaient déjà un problème
qu'on est en train de regarder le canada
comment on peut s'assurer d'avoir des
tarifs qui sont plus raisonnables parce
que quand c'est rendu complet 1000 1200
$ pour un aller-retour à l'intérieur du
québec
je trouve ça exagéré mesdames messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue à l'émission c'est
françois legault le premier minis du
québec mais aussi et co fondateur d'air
transat qui commentait la transaction
qui sont venus aujourd'hui qui a été
acceptée entre air canada et transat
donc air canada achète air transat et
nous là dedans ça nous laisse où on a
déjà l'impression qu'on peine ou billets
d'avion trop cher et on se demande donc
si l'achat de transat par ea canada va
faire grimper les prix
je vous rappelle que la transaction est
évaluée à 520 millions de dollars
elle doit encore être approuvé par les
deux tiers des actionnaires de transat
il y en a déjà qui font connaître
franchement qui sont peut-être pas très
contents du montant versé par air canada
pour acheter air transat avant le bureau
de la concurrence va aussi devoir donner
son aval
air canada assure que la marque air
transat sera maintenu et que le siège
social de transats à montréal va
survivre mais avec un joueur indépendant
de moins est ce que nous on va y perdre
au change avec moi en gré des marées il
est le président de la section québec de
l'association canadienne des agences de
voyage monsieur démarrer bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous qui vous y connaissez la
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
va y perdre au change qu'on va payé nos
billets plus chers parce qu' un
compétiteur de moi écoutez c'est sûr que
ça va changer un peu la structure de
des montants alloués aux voyages comme
on discutait avec d'autres agents de
voyages la période peut-être qu'ils sont
les bases période où il ya plusieurs
transporteurs la diminution du nombre de
transporteurs pu faire que les prix de
base saison augmente alors basse saison
il ya plus de places dans les avions
existants il ya plus de compétition
cette compétition faire en sorte que les
prix baissent exactement
alors son air canada et air transat
auront juste un avion à remplir malles
identités fortes chances que moins
d'offres le prix la demande
ça ça va être peut-être une période où
les consommateurs vont être
particulièrement touchés mais comment on
le sait on sait que westjet a été acheté
par onex et le but d'onex aussi c'est
une croissance au niveau des vols
alors est-ce qu'ils vont s'attaquer au
marché je sais qu'il voulait s'attaquer
énormément marché européen pour faire
compétition avec transat et air canada
passé de 60% semble-t-il du marché
européen
possiblement et écoutez j'ai donc mais
mais west jet pourrait vouloir essayer
d'avoir des parts de marché l'absolu
mans fc
c'est bon ça c'est bon c'est bon aussi
parce que les vols de transit par de
montréal où partent de toronto alors le
fait qu'il ya discussions avec air
canada
ça va permettre d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
des add-on alors les gens vont pouvoir
partir parce qu'il ya des vols de
toronto sont plus fréquents par exemple
sur la grande bretagne tandis que bien
entendu de montréal beaucoup plus de
vols sur la france
alors ça va permettre aux gens de
toronto de prendre un vol air canada
jusqu'à montréal et continuer la france
en basse saison vous avez dit qu'il
pourrait y avoir un effet en haute
saison et ce qui est vrai parce que
air transat rempli des avions aussi en
haute saison c'est-à-dire l'été je
présume que c'est sa haute saison
écoutez si on parle de vacances on sait
que noël congés scolaires ce sont les
héros de saison et les vacances de la
construction
on sait qu'on peut dire c'est les toits
très haute saison aura très haute saison
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un effet à la
hausse
non je ne crois pas parce que il faut
quand même qu'ils remplissent tous leurs
avions à cet effet là je pense que les
prix vont rester sensiblement les mêmes
même s'il ya une petite croissance le
prix au cours des dernières années
je crois que si c'est assez stable les
prix parce que si on regarde sur les
trente dernières années la croissance
des prix sur les billets d'avion
reflètent pas nécessairement ce qu'on a
payé pour les sens où la nourriture mais
on a toujours l'impression de payer nos
billets d'avion trop cher c'est sûr que
yo yo les clients qui les dernières
minutes et y'a pas le choix ces dates
sont fixes alors c'est quoi le truc pour
pour payer moins cher à part de vouloir
partir au mois de janvier pour le
groenland banane comme n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde chose à faire c'est
que la structure d'une bière avion d'une
compagnie aérienne c'est tournage est à
l'avant ce que les prix ce sont les
pluies les plus bas dans l'avion alors
lorsqu'ils ont vendu leurs premiers 30
sièges les prélèvements de 50 dollars
les autres 30e alors ça fonctionne comme
ça tranche de 30 y est c'est pour ça que
des classes de service et quand un agent
voyage vous dit excuse-moi des prix est
remonté on a changé de place
ça veut pas dire vous allez est en
classe affaires non ça veut juste dire
que vous êtes tombé dans une nouvelle
tarification
alors c'est sûr que pour quelqu'un qui
veut partir et qui a déjà planifié
acheter son billet d'avant c'est une
bonne chose qui peut acheter la première
fois qu'on magazine on peut le vérifier
parce qu'il ya des ventes ponctuelles
c'est sûr qu'un bon agent de voyage
c'est à peu près quelle date les ventes
de sièges sont annoncés par les
compagnies aériennes
alors que ce soit air france air canada
un faut surveiller les ventes est-ce
qu'ils sont nés des dates flexibles
aussi ça aide
oui absolument parce que si vous avez
les dates flexibles à ce moment là on
peut jouer parce que comme vous
expliquer les sièges qui sont vendus ça
se peut que la fin de semaine des sièges
soit beaucoup plus vendus classement oui
on nous dit de pas magasiner la fin de
semaine parce que plus de monde qui
étendrait magazines etc ça donc j'ai
fait monter les prix exacts il ya plus
de monde qui partit fin de semaine à
cause des vacances des choses pas
toujours de faire fonctionner dans notre
avion les premiers sièges sont déjà
partis souvent les deuxièmes 30e son
parti alors le jeudi ils ont juste dit
les premiers 30 yens c'est un exemple
alors on verra quel sera l'impact d'un
petit tableau qui a été concocté par nos
amis de r d économies sur d'autres
fusions ou achat de deux compagnies
aériennes ces dernières années des temps
nord-ouest en 2009 user user un mec
america west en 2005 american airlines
et tu t'es w en 2001 ça a provoqué une
augmentation de 5,6 pour cent des prix
des billets et us airways et piémont
airlines 189 +20 3% alors on verra si ça
se reflète évidemment dans la
transaction air canada air transat se
démarque moi je pense que dans les
exemples sont des données les grosses
compagnies aériennes avaient à peu près
les mêmes marchés
ah ouais alors tandis que piémont ou des
choses comme ça avait démarché plus
locale régionale c'est à dire écoutez
comme monsieur legault lavezzi si vous
voulez monter à chicoutimi
malheureusement vous allez payer bien
lui sera le même prix qu'au père est
pourtant clair qu par l'exemple est ce
qu'un dernier qui sont on a l'impression
que entre air canada air transat air
canada charge toujours plus cher que air
transat c'est ce que c'est une véritable
impression ou c'est juste une légende
urbaine
écoutez c'est une véritable de ce
nouveau rite et parce que la compagnie
aérienne air canada a une structure
beaucoup plus lourde
80 on sait que transat au départ ce sont
des avions nolisés alors c'est des
avions qui nécessite moins une structure
opérationnelle
air canada qu'on le veuille ou non est
obligé d'avoir des gens
chibougamau bagad ville exact ça veut
pas dire que les prix vont monter aussi
à travers air canada prend le rencontre
où moi je pense parce que j'ai pas la
boule de cristal c'est ce que je suis
pas l'ennuyer des administrateurs de ces
compagnies l'heure mais je pense moi que
les deux compagnies vont rester sur le
même niveau la vente à ce qu'air canada
a acheté transat c'est les destinations
en europe perd transat à négocier
beaucoup de direct de vol dirais que air
canada s'est lui coûterait trop cher à
négocier parce que les compagnies rien
dans leurs négociations ils sont obligés
de faire un peu plus de donnant-donnant
que les compagnies charter une compagnie
charter sont réputés prenez du tourisme
alors seulement les conflits pays sont
heureux exactement tandis que air canada
s'ils sont un vrai homme destinations
air france doit exiger par exemple des
veulent dire sur québec
c'est donnant-donnant pour les aiguiller
les châteaux c'est pas l'heure
l'avantagent que air canada et en
achetant transat il va s'ouvrir un
marché qu'il disait et à moindre coût
fut emprisonné alors on touche du bois
pour nous lie et d'avions monsieur
démarrer merci beaucoup merci